von thomas andre sandra johannes welche
verantwortung haben wir als medien immer
wieder zu berichten gegen das vergessen
eine große eine kaum zu überschätzende
es ist einerseits das berichten über die
vergangenheit denn wir haben es gerade
front row uhr gehört die zeitzeuginnen
und zeitzeugen sterben aus es ist eine
generation die nicht mehr präsent sein
kann und so ist es jetzt an uns zu
erinnern was damals geschehen ist was
aus deutschland für ein horror über
viele andere länder über juden aus
unserer mitte gebracht wurde an den
massenmord damit das nie wieder wirklich
auch präsent bleibt die medien sind auch
insofern gefordert als sie auf den 9 und
ja bedauerlicherweise in den letzten
monaten und jahren wieder extrem er
startenden antisemitismus den hass auf
juden wirklich hinweisen müssen und da
eben wieder auf dem linken noch auf dem
rechten auge noch auf den augen mit
denen wir vielleicht auch über migration
berichten blind zahlen dürfen in dem
moment in dem in deutschland
antisemitismus geäußert wird judenhass
sichtbar wird ist es die aufgabe der
medien mit größter schärfe und härte
darauf hinzuweisen denn johannes es gibt
tatsächlich auch erhebungen die zeigen
es gibt auch viele menschen die wollen
sich nicht mit diesem thema beschäftigen
sind sogar genervt davon wie ordnet du
das 1 ja das ist bedauerlich und das ist
in der tat ein großes problem denn ich
glaube wenn man sagt wir wollen das
hinter uns lassen dann schließt man
gleichzeitig auch aus dass wir eine
bessere zukunft schaffen und dass wir es
ausschließen und verhindern dass jemals
wieder irgendwo auf der welt so etwas
passiert
ich glaube andererseits dass es zur
verantwortung auch gehört die menschen
da draußen die ja auch ihr persönliches
leben haben ihre eigenen sorgen haben
somit zu nehmen und so in zu informieren
dass es für sie eben nachvollziehbar
bleibt aber
wenn jetzt jemand sagt das thema ist für
mich abgeschlossen ich habe daran
überhaupt kein interesse das geht mich
nichts an das halte ich für falsch denn
es ist doch so wir kennen das alle wenn
man durch eine deutsche großstadt läuft
die stolpersteine sind zum glück
mittlerweile sehr präsent aus so vielen
häusern wurden damals juden gezerrt und
ermordet und das gehört einfach zur
deutschen geschichte und deswegen muss
es auch heute noch präsent sein und es
muss jedem der in diesem land ist klar
sein was ja mal passiert ist was
bedeutet dann gedenken heute konkret für
unsere gesellschaft gedenken heute
bedeutet einerseits die erinnerung
wachzuhalten darüber haben wir gerade
gesprochen aber gedenken heute bedeutet
zumindest für mich auch eine sehr
konkrete ableitung daraus es gibt eben
ein land das es israel dort können juden
in sicherheit leben denn viele von ihnen
werden ja auch heute noch vielleicht
nicht im selben ausmaß aber doch
verfolgt bedroht der antisemitismus
grassiert insbesondere im westen israel
ist die sichere
zu und ist der sicheren zufluchtsort für
juden wird nun auch wieder existenziell
bedroht insbesondere von iran einem land
das an der atombombe arbeitet mit dem
ausgesprochenen ziel israel zu
vernichten und wenn man nun eben heute
gedenkt dann bedeutet für mich die damit
einhergehende verantwortung auch israel
zu schützen waffenexporte nach israel zu
ermöglichen und durch eine
unmissverständliche außenpolitik
klarzumachen dass wir dieser im land
dauerhaft verbunden sind vielen dank
johannes boot für deinen besuch heute
hier und zu diesem wichtigen thema das
wir niemals vergessen dürfen dankeschön
danke euch